garyun kyu turned to kickstarter to self
publish your book it was a process
actually it was it was it was an
educational learning curve for me it
took me a while to figure out that I
didn't want to publish her that I did
want to self publish and the relevant
reason primarily is I really wanted
manifest destiny I wanted to own my own
intellectual property and not give it up
and not be on a royalty basis with a
publisher who wasn't going to market it
anyway I thought you know what I really
like air deeply about what's in the book
it represents 25 years of my life and
I've always been in love with the
storytellers with the creatives and I
want to get this information out so I
thought if I own it I'm more free to do
that in more innovative ways so number
one I thought on yourself published the
second step was then how do you self
publish it's a very fast shifting
landscape this world of publishing it
it's it's every day it's changing by the
hour and I I thought a minute I thought
okay I've decided some things that are
good for me and there's a lot of moving
parts so I thought okay I'm going to
hire layout designers and people to e
format it and book cover design it and
I'm gonna hire a printer and order a
certain book right and on and on it
there's a long laundry list right I
thought you know what if I do all that
that's great I'll have a beautiful book
and no audience and I have to start from
zero then I just then I thought I
started these conversations asking
people about crowdsourcing crowdfunding
in particular about IndieGoGo about
Kickstarter and I realized Kickstarter
really was a phenomenal opportunity not
just because in and and and the least of
it was the fundraising what was most
interesting to me was I get this period
of time over which to build a community
I get to find my brand evangelists I get
to really put my message out almost
serialize it right over time and drive
traffic from all quarters
from traditional media and my database
and other people to this place called
Kickstarter it's very dynamic so this to
me it was the perfect community building
opportunity precede pre you know just
till the soil how much pre-planning did
you do before you launched the campaign
and what sources did you go to to gather
information on crowdfunding well I have
a my my partner Morgan is a very astute
about social strategy so she knew a fair
amount about it to begin with I did not
I had to sort of study from the
beginning yeah but she brought me up to
speak fairly quickly and then we just
asked a lot of people who we'd seen
doing it that we had contacts too and
you just Google and you you know today
how do you learn you Google and you ask
people and you get on social media ask
people but it became very clear that
Kickstarter was that platform that was
the best fit for us and and I'll be
honest with you you know it's it's not
quite as neat and clean as you would
hope you use your best judgment you go
with your gut because I think your gut
is your best guide for this kind of a
social experience it's not a sells job
you can't you just it's got to be about
something bigger than that so it felt
like if we just say if we're really
vulnerable and honest and candid and and
committed to what we're doing and put
that message out whether it's the video
or the copy or however we present our
choice of our ways of saying thank you
the perks that we put together the
people that we enrolled from my film
industry community to be a part of that
if we created that as the ethos the
fabric of who we are and what we're
doing we stayed true to that how bad
could we fail so that's how we began was
just sort of seeded the pants and we've
learned so much every week and it's only
been two weeks into the campaign
learned so much well it looks like what
you're almost 80% funded we're weird
we're just 90% funded and we're about
halfway through and now we just did a
Twitter tweet a thon today and we're
getting some traditional media to drive
traffic to it over the coming 10 days or
week and I think we're learning how to
not sustain energy but actually build it
and create a bigger conversation and
bring more invite more people in and
what's interesting is how much people
are ready to say yes people really like
to be part of this kind of open
conversation about something they deeply
care about and not they don't deeply
care about it because it's necessarily
screenwriting and they're not a
screenwriter it's about creativity it's
about seeing people realize in this case
maybe it's even seeing me realize a
dream of mine there's something that
really tugs at people about that and
it's cool
you